blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpackman so as we continue to head
to the 2022 midterm elections we are now
under a year away from those midterm
elections I was talking to our YouTube
rep yesterday and he feels and I agree
that the 22 2022 midterm uh season is
sort of going to get going in Earnest
probably in mid to late March or early
April this year it's going to be quite
wild and I don't know that it's going to
be particularly good for Democrats
there's a real possibility I won't say a
probability but there's a real
possibility that Republicans take the
house and the Senate and many
governorships in November next November
under a year from now and one of the
things that I want to let you know is
that
the four-year nightmare of trump has
really changed aspects of our politics
in a way that goes beyond Trump to the
degree that Trump is no longer a
candidate but his presidency impacts the
people that are candidates as an example
of that I present to you the reality
that many 2022 Republican candidates
have been accused of assaulting or
threatening to murder people and that in
times past it would be far less likely
that these individuals would continue to
be viable candidates for office but they
are today and I believe to some degree
this is thanks to the coarsening of the
discourse and the
absolutely absurd way in which Donald
Trump's candidacy and ultimately
presidency has
diminished any serious minimum standard
for Behavior
um from candidates for public office so
very good article in slate about this
Ben Mathis Lilly writes about it and
says things might be different by
November of 22 but as it stands right
now Republicans are in a good position
to retake Congress I agree
the incumbent Democratic president's
approval rating is low off your
elections and swing states are tilting
Red Rising costs are forcing certain
bloggers himself included who don't
enjoy macroeconomics not just to pay
more for groceries but to read articles
about economics
um the key phrase is conventional
indicators and he points out that things
are a lot different in this kind of
trump era
uh pointing out
that in recent days a right-wing
Pennsylvania activist and former Army
Ranger Sean Parnell who was endorsed by
Trump in the state's 2022 Senate primary
two months ago
um is now involved in an ongoing trial
in which parnell's ex-wife testified
that he once strangled her and has hit
their children
in 2019 Parnell made an appearance on a
Fox Nation talk show in which he blamed
feminism for creating quote women
tyrants and asserted men don't want to
put up with the BS of high maintenance
narcissistic women he has denied
allegations of abuse
similar accusations have been made
against three other candidates and
potentially competitive 2022 races
either endorsed by Trump or who have a
shot a good chance at earning his
support
in Georgia Trump has endorsed the Senate
campaign of former football player
Herschel Walker Walker's ex-wife and one
of his ex-girlfriends have both accused
him of threatening to kill them to kill
them
his ex-wife who received a protective
order against him said he once pointed a
gun at her walker denies the
ex-girlfriend's accusation and says he
doesn't remember threatening his now
ex-wife we then go to the Ohio 16th
District currently represented by
Republican Anthony Gonzalez who is not
running for re-election
um Trump has endorsed a one-time Aid of
his named Max Miller
former White House Press Secretary
Stephanie Grisham says Miller pushed her
against the wall and slapped her while
they were dating during Trump's
presidency Miller denies it per the
Washington Post Miller also pleaded no
contest to two misdemeanor charges
related to an alleged 2007 assault the
charges were later dismissed as part of
a program for first-time offenders and
guilty to a disorderly conduct charge
related to a fight outside a bar okay so
there's Max Miller
moving on in Missouri former Governor
Eric greitens is running for Senate has
appeared with Rudy Giuliani hired Donald
Trump Jr's girlfriend Kimberly Guilfoyle
as the national chair of his campaign
greitens resigned as governor in 2018
after a woman who was not his wife said
he had slapped her
intimidated her into performing oral sex
on him and taken a nude photo of her
without permission that he told her he
would release if she spoke about their
Affair he denies it says the affair was
consensual however an investigative
Committee of state legislators found the
woman's version of events credible
um this is uh I don't want to say that
prior to Trump these folks definitely
would have had their campaigns ended by
allegations and remember allegations are
allegations in some of these cases
they've been investigated and found
credible in other cases we have denials
Etc
but prior to Trump many of these folks
would never think to even run because of
the disadvantage that the allegations
would have
now that Trump has proven proven that it
really doesn't matter to about half of
the voters in this country what you're
accused of or in some cases even what
you admit to
the floodgates have been completely and
totally opened to any kind of character
no matter how unsuited to public office
no matter how vile the allegations
against them this is an example of a
change that may be permanent that may be
permanent thanks to the coarsening of
discourse and American politics thanks
to Donald Trump and trumpism we will see
how these people do
I have for you today one of those
stories that
gosh darn it it's sort of a feel-good
story somebody did something great and
we can be glad about that
but it's something great that was only
necessary because of how dystopian
circumstances are in the United States
what do I mean you'll see as soon as I
give you the details headline Stacy
Abrams who we like Stacy Abrams pack
wipes out 212 million dollars in medical
debt
for a hundred and eight thousand people
wow what a beautiful thing to do
Newsweek writes a political organization
led by Stacy Abrams has paid off the
medical debts owed by 108 000 people in
five states the fair fight political
action committee donated 1.34 million
dollars to the non-profit organization
rest in peace medical debt to clear
debts that carried a face value of 212
million dollars the state where the most
people received the payoffs was Georgia
69
000 people had medical bills paid 27 000
arizonans had their debts paid 8 000
louisianans and 2000 mississippians and
alabamans have had their debts paid
Abram says I know firsthand how medical
costs and a broken Health Care System
put families further into debt
etc etc what a beautiful thing to do
but this is another one of those
feel-good stories and it is a great
thing that uh Stacy Abrams pack did it's
a great thing
uh unburdening people of medical debt in
this way
these are stories that should not exist
remember that show Breaking Bad arguably
one of the best
uh dramatic television programs in
history I would argue I would put it up
there with any other show
um that is a show whose premise wouldn't
work in Canada
it wouldn't work in Denmark right
um teacher gets sick with cancer
and starts making and selling meth
to pay for his medical treatment
you understand and then this reminds me
of course of little Johnny did a bake
sale to raise money for little Emily's
cancer treatment how lovely shouldn't be
necessary dystopian that it even exists
in one of the richest countries in the
world so with all of these stories I
sort of repeat what has been my
perspective for a long time we can find
the actions of individuals admirable
while finding the circumstances that
precipitated them disgusting and immoral
and that's exactly what we have here you
know you talk to people in other
countries medical debt what do you mean
medical debt what does that mean exactly
and in many countries particularly
countries that are as rich as ours
medical bankruptcy is not a thing
medical debt in this way is not a thing
and Stacy Abrams is throwing Millions
1.3 million dollars
to pay off what was 212 million dollars
of face value of medical expenditures
for over a hundred thousand different
people she's great
what was done is fantastic shouldn't be
necessary and just another signal about
how broken many of our systems are at
this point in time I would love to hear
from from you about it if your
perspective is different let me know but
admirable individual actions based on
completely horrifying circumstances
Beyond Stacey Abrams control Stacy
Abrams is working within the system to
try to improve circumstances for
different people uh okay next week I
want to let everybody know
we are going to be on alert for the
verdict in the Kyle Rittenhouse trial
the case is going to the jury we've been
covering it for a while I just want to
let everybody know it's conceivable
because sometimes you only get an hour
to 90 minutes notice that the verdict
has been reached my intention is to
cover that live uh we've been covering
the trial daily since the start and I
really want to make every effort to kind
of complete that depending on when it
happens Monday Tuesday Wednesday we
don't know how long the jury is going to
deliberate it could be two weeks we just
have no idea
um it may throw off when some of the
shows over the next couple of weeks are
published so I'm just asking for you uh
from you for a little bit of latitude as
far as that goes going forward in terms
of the schedule upcoming we're going to
be here all of next week the following
week it's Thanksgiving week here in the
United States we will only be doing a
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday show we'll
run repeats on Thursday and Friday but
we will be doing a short week Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and then we'll be back
for with everything else normal Etc one
other programming note we don't usually
promote interviews ahead of time because
it happens maybe one out of 20.
one out of 18 guests Bales at the last
second and that's why we often don't
promote interviews in advance
dozens and dozens of you have said
please talk to Andrew Yang about his
third party
we're going to be um we the inner we're
actually we're recording the interview
with Andrew Yang in the next week but it
is scheduled to air on November 23rd
okay so the second to last show before
Thanksgiving we are planning to have a
wide-ranging interview with Andrew Yang
we will talk about the forward party we
will talk about a lot of different
things if you have things you want me to
ask Andrew Yang about you can email info
davidpackman.com and let me know so with
that we'll take a quick break let me
know your thoughts where you are on the
Written House trial you can find me on
Twitter at dpacman
um and we're going to be back with your
calls I'm going to go over your emails
we've got a lot of other things to
discuss on this tremendous Friday show
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the David packman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app I just
listened to this is your mind on Plants
by the great Michael pollen super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcast two blinkist takes
long episodes of popular podcasts and
distills them into audio you can listen
to and 15 minutes with blinkist you can
become knowledgeable about so many
different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blink is for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below
remember that the David packman show is
primarily sponsored by folks who sign up
on my website joinpakman.com would love
for you to grab a membership we do an
extra show every day for those very
folks and would love to talk to many of
you
um on the bonus show comments as well so
sign up at joinpakman.com let's go to
the phone lines we do that via Discord
at davidpackman.com
Discord I want to start today let's go
to Andy from Eastern Iowa Andy you're on
the air what's on your mind my friend
uh do I sound okay Andy you sound
absolutely perfect
awesome
got a real quick one for you uh what do
you think is the first like steps for
younger people getting into politics to
kind of get more involved even before
maybe they're old enough to actually run
for something you mean
yes get on get involved in a campaign
and when I say a campaign it doesn't
have to be
a candidate campaign it could even be an
issue based campaign it could be maybe
the city council where you are wants to
bring Municipal Broadband
um get involved in advocating for that
if it's going to be
um if it's going to be a voter
initiative a ballot initiative or
whatever just get involved in something
you can help on campaigns in most places
there's no age limit find something you
care about maybe it's a candidate maybe
it's an issue and just jump in and get
involved
awesome all right thank you my pleasure
all right uh Andy from Eastern Iowa very
much appreciate that let's go next
um all right I mean maybe against my
better judgment I'm curious what he has
to say let's go to Jimmy from Philly
Jimmy you are on the air
hey David how you doing I'm doing well
thank you Jimmy
David I just wanted to say that listen
to that prosecutor kind of reminded me
of when I talk to you
I'm sorry can your which process what
are you talking about Jimmy
so listening to the prosecutor in uh the
Kyle case
yes reminds me and what other Kyle is
there David my God you've been doing
this for eight hours
um
you're good at throwing me for a loop
David you know like uh uh yeah listen to
that prosecutor reminds me of speaking
to you because he was trying to trap
Kyle into saying different things which
is the same thing you do with me and at
the end of the day when I don't say you
just lie and say that I said
um I thought you were going to say that
the prosecutor reminded me of me because
of his incredible Poise preparation and
how articulate he was
basically disregarded the judge's orders
many times which then pissed off the
judge yeah and most of your chat thinks
that he's biased towards Kyle now he
purposely pissed off the judge
and then you got a reaction from the
judge I mean it's very clear I mean he's
disregarded the judge's orders numerous
times you can't do that in a courtroom
surprising to hold him a contempt well
Jimmy I really appreciate your legal
insights what do you expect in terms of
the verdict
oh I I tend to agree with you I I think
that uh I don't think that he will be
found guilty of murder but at one gun
charge maybe he maybe he gets found
guilty on that I'm not sure
you know I don't think the kid goes to
prison clearly the judge ain't gonna
hurt him right so what's going on at
your place it sounds wild there's Chimes
and different elements
what's happening at your place it sounds
crazy today oh hold on sure somebody's
trolling me David give me a second oh my
pleasure
things happening in real time I I don't
understand why this is happening
well I'm sorry oh my God I don't know
why
I don't know why this is
what's for dinner tonight Jimmy
uh well I just ordered ordered a um
uh uh uh what would you call it uh oh
Jesus
um chicken Caesar salad oh okay do you
like it with uh with the anchovies or
without
no anchovies no I ordered tomatoes with
David for the life of me I cannot
understand
why this is going on you mean white
people eat fish or what I don't know
what music okay all right Jimmy thank
you hey Jimmy I do want to move on but
it's always a pleasure speaking I'm
sorry David
okay all right there's Jimmy from Philly
delivering
um
absolutely critical and incisive legal
opinion on the Kyle Rittenhouse case
let's go next to um I'd like to speak to
Lynn in California Lynn how are you
today
fine how are you I'm doing well what's
on your mind
first I want to thank you for being a
calm and informative source of
progressive news well thank you
and I've been watching The Rittenhouse
trial and you've made it clear what your
opinion is I'm wondering if there's any
testimony that would change that
you mean is there is there is there
testimony that would make me think that
a guilty for homicide is coming
s you know what's really really tough
about an affirmative defense like
self-defense is that you're not denying
that he did the thing you're basically
saying his State of Mind was that he
thought he might be killed and with a
standard of Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
it's Rel un unless the circumstances
were different I find it very hard for
the prosecution to prove a negative that
at no time did Kyle fear for his life so
I don't really think it's about
testimony I think it's about the
circumstances and the facts
yeah I agree as much as I would like to
see him found guilty I can definitely
see how a juror would
see if there was a reasonable doubt as
well yeah and the thing about I would
like to see him be guilty I think that
he's guilty of a lot of things that
aren't crimes like for example it's an
example of disastrous parenting where a
17 year old even thinks that this is
something that you would do I think it's
a an example of our disastrous and toxic
gun culture in the United States militia
ideology
vigilantism it's all of these different
things for what he's charged with and we
we have to see what the jury
instructions are it doesn't seem that
guilty would be in line with the case
that the reason that the defense will
reasonably make about self-defense
that's my take
I agree and the only thing he said he
knows about AR-15s are they make him
look cool he doesn't know the damage
they do or the ammunition that's used
which he may have been lying about quite
frankly I think that was part of making
you know stepping away from being very
aware of exactly what the gun would do I
think that was he I think he feigned
ignorance on that but still you know
it's all it's crazy it's all crazy
okay thank you and I agree with you
girlfriend the mustache should really go
oh wow well it may go soon it may go
soon
okay thank you all right there's Lynn
from California
um very much appreciate that call let's
go oh I don't know I mean there's just
so many people here what oh let's go to
Ohio what about Maria in Columbus Ohio
Maria you're on the air simply on mute
and we'll be able to chat
and Maria from Ohio last chance to
unmute yourself so that we can talk
well that's too bad I was looking
forward to speaking with Maria let's try
instead
um
why don't we go to Steve from Illinois
Steve you're on the air
hey David hey how are you
good
um I was wondering what you thought I
mean I know that you probably agree with
the Mandate but I was wondering what you
thought of the Biden Administration
still telling companies to follow their
uh vaccine Amanda even though it's
getting held up in the courts right now
don't you kind of find that
um wrong in a sense if the courts are
kind of holding up in the Biden
Administration telling companies to not
follow what the courts are saying well
correct me if I'm wrong the that
requirement call it a protocol or
mandate whatever you want to call it I
don't believe it goes into effect for
several more weeks right so I I think my
understanding you correct me if I'm
wrong my understanding is that the the
Biden Administration is saying plan on
this being something you that will be in
place I understand that right now it's
being frozen but it hasn't actually gone
into effect yet has it
no the man hasn't come into effect but I
guess like the fact that like it's
getting held up right now and then I get
er I guess them saying continue going on
so that planning on the common effect is
you I guess do you think that the body
May strange things that then get through
the courts then or do you I guess I
think in my mind it kind of seems like
no I think it will be through the course
I think it's reason I mean Ronald Clane
said on on NBC I think it was over the
weekend we believe ultimately this is
going to be upheld you know the New
Orleans circuit appeals court there uh
is is very conservative this is unlikely
to be a decision that stays um so I I
think I mean listen we'll we'll know
soon I don't think the Biden
Administration is doing anything wrong
by saying we believe this ultimately
will be in force yeah
all right that I see I guess I see your
point when I was looking at it I guess
in my mind it it came off more of
keep doing it even though it's getting
held up rather than it looks like it's
gonna be go through
um on that end right well certainly keep
vaccinating is something like listen
continue vaccinating employees makes
perfect sense
I guess yeah I get the vaccination I I
uh vaccination point on there I guess I
was misreading I guess on my you you
explained it very well like the
situation was going on I guess when I
was looking into it it kind of came off
in a different way on its own fair
enough all right I appreciate that call
Steve thank you uh there's Steve from
Illinois
very powerful call let's go next to Tina
from Asheville North Carolina Tina how
are you
oh my goodness all right now Tina if
we're gonna talk you've got to turn off
that notification noise because it is
just it's gonna destroy any ability you
and I have to communicate so you got to
turn off notifications in Discord
Tina
can you hear me now David I I can still
hear you but those are still continuing
to bling if you can turn off
notifications that would be great oh
gosh I don't know how to do that it's my
first time on Discord oh dear okay it's
still blinking it hasn't for now
okay okay I think it was me because I
didn't know if I was meeting or meeting
okay
okay
um uh long time subscriber first time
callers uh thank you for picking on me
and I just actually wanted to ask you
about
um how like how to speak about Hispanic
people and I just wanted to know like
what the difference is between like
Latin like if you're talking about
Hispanic people in this country do you
refer to them as a Latino or is Hispanic
okay I mean I know you're Argentinian so
I'm just wondering like which one is is
more acceptable listen there are people
who feel very very strongly about this
and they say the right word is Hispanic
but not Latino the right word is Latino
but not Hispanic there are people who
say that these words have different
definitions like for example Hispanic
would include Spain but not Brazil
whereas Latino would include all of
Latin America but not Spain with Brazil
maybe being part of it or maybe not and
there's a couple other countries in
South America that you could argue
culturally or not not a part of Latin
America I am not like a big I think both
were I don't find either word offensive
I understand that the words may have
slightly different meanings but if we're
all trying to communicate in good faith
I know what someone means when they
refer to Latino folks and Hispanic folks
and I use both terms sometimes so I'm
not like a big stickler but there's
different elements of Academia that
would have particular points of view and
you know you ask someone else you'll get
a different answer Tina that's the truth
oh okay all right thank you so much
David my pleasure there's Tina from
Asheville North Carolina with a number
of different technical aspects of the
call that dramatically improved as we
went
let's go next to DB from Virginia am I
pronouncing that right DB
develop yeah can you hear me yes I can
can you hear him yes I can oh what's up
man how you doing good how are you
I'm good man so I'm watching the case it
looks like
okay you're cutting out DB so you said
you're watching the case and it looks
like and then you cut out right when you
were saying what it looks like
it's about 50 50. to me 50 50 in terms
of all the charges or on the on the
homicide
like yeah all the shores is pretty much
yeah I'm just not sure uh I mean how how
is the prosecution going to eliminate
from the jury's belief that Written
House really feared for his life how are
they going to prove to the jury yeah
that's what I was thinking yeah yeah
that's what I was thinking too but then
again it's like
he pointed the gut at him you know what
I'm saying so it's like this is the
United States you know what I'm saying
so well but hold on a second baby whoa
um Rosenbaum didn't have a gun right
Rosenbaum didn't point a gun at Carlton
a Kyle Rittenhouse the argument that
Rittenhouse makes is that after the
first shot Rosenbaum attempted to grab
the gun we're already kind of in the
weeds but I I still see it as a big hill
to overcome to say he didn't fear for
his life
but yeah this judge is crazy man
that's definitely crazy the judges out
there yeah I mean listen I know that
early Jimmy earlier Jimmy from Philly
said the judge is actually trying to
help the prosecution I don't see that at
all I see the the judge interrupting on
the day of the Written House testimony
five or six times at Key moments where
Rittenhouse was sort of falling apart
um I see the decisions mostly favoring
the defense I I see the judge more of as
an as an asset to the defense
yeah so it's like and another thing a
small thing outside of this
uh Joe Biden man I feel sorry like past
this year man I live in Virginia yeah
slaughtered and slaughtered bloodbath oh
yeah it was no it was no signs bruh it
was bad
wait but you're saying you're saying for
the young and McAuliffe race right yes
man I was like yo nobody voted that I
knew you know nobody voted low turnout
in this election
yeah so well it's uh Virginia is going
to be a real question mark for Democrats
uh in the next couple years I think
that's clear
yeah yeah well we'll see all right thank
you for the call yeah no I think about
it I'm gonna let you go because I have
so many people holding great to speak to
you I I do really appreciate it we're
going to take a very quick break and
then we're gonna be right back at it uh
and take some more phone calls in a
moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
let's hear from a few more people in the
audience we're doing it via Discord
davidpackman.com
Discord is the place to find the
mechanism for phone calls
let's go to oh let's try Maria from
Maria from Columbus says that she's
ready Maria you're on the air
hey can you hear me I can hear you now
Maria what was happening before
I have no idea I have a Discord open on
my laptop and now I'm on my phone so got
it don't know what that's about sorry
well I'm glad you were able to make it
on
yeah me too uh I'm really sorry about
your Twitch ban it's a pretty [ __ ]
in my opinion yes please don't swear
remember this goes on the radio so every
time you swear we've got to bleep that
Pat please make a note we're gonna bleep
Maria yes the twitch ban is a
disappointment for sure
hard to talk with anyone else about it
everyone else seems very annoyed about
the whole thing
um I am as well I'm very frustrated the
judge is
insane
yeah I don't I mean uh I'm trying to
sort of be as as least hyperbolic as
possible about the judge but in
particular in particular when he
completely fell for this entire
um uh objection from the defense that
zooming in a picture is in some way
equivalent to algorithmically creating
3D images from a still from a still
image and the judge was sort of like I
don't know what they're doing yeah it
was it was just humiliating it's just
like what just like he's completely not
understanding what's going on
yep I feel like he should have some sort
of uh education on on what he's judging
about technology-wise there yes yes and
the burden of proof where just the mere
bogus objection from Kyle rittenhouse's
attorney led the judge to say to the
prosecution you're gonna have to like
bring in a witness and prove that this
is this stuff that hasn't been altered
it's like wait a second there's been no
serious allegation that it has it's just
some vague idea that rittenhouse's
attorney had it was all bizarre
completely yeah what do you think will
be the verdict though
uh realistically yeah I I think he's
gonna get away without any issue which I
wish was not the case but you know I I
don't think
from how it's going I don't I don't
think he's gonna get get any sort of
punishment yeah here's my real issue
I've said I think self-defense is
plausible in the homicide charges
particularly with Anthony Huber I think
it's totally plausible the sick thing is
that this kid is already a product of
the disgusting gun culture of the United
States and his acquittal is going to
fire up the militia and gun people even
more he'll be seen as a hero he'll be
invited to sign headshots and speak at
gun conventions and whatnot when this is
actually a tragedy what took place
um that's that's really my concern here
I agree completely yeah yeah
so um from the standpoint of third
vaccinations have you gotten yours yet
I'm going very very soon I've got an
appointment actually uh in the in the
next day or so and I uh I will report my
symptoms but yes I'm getting my third
dose very soon
I wasn't after the second dose but now I
am you mean literally magnetic or you
just now have a Magnetic Personality
just quite literally magnetic oh there's
a there's a lot of metal
that's why my
actually I think that explains why you
we weren't able to hear you earlier
actually
yeah
and by the way that's a joke Maria we're
all kidding we're all kidding around I
am kidding yeah thank you Maria
appreciate the call
thank you all right there's Maria from
Columbus Ohio
pretty damn close to a perfect phone
call I would say let's go next to Steph
from Glasgow
oh wow
welcome
hi
um I just wanted to say as a person not
from America really I couldn't tell from
your accent you're I thought you were
from Texas
oh wow well
um
I just find the whole gun culture thing
insane yeah it's
it baffles me and I've actually just
been saying to myself earlier like if
you were claiming self-defense would you
not have like here you would just kick
the person and make them leave you alone
like what's the what's the automatic
reaction to like point a gun and shoot
somebody that baffles me this is exactly
what I'm talking about when I'm saying
you know we're looking at these videos
of 20 people walking around with long
guns and all of this insanity and we're
trying to focus in on this narrow
question of like Was Written House
justified in shooting the people that he
shot
much of the world is having exactly your
reaction which is how is even the
context remotely considered acceptable
in any way at all that this is even a
thing that happens
yep
yeah it's it's just it's just a totally
different culture and it it's scary
because he's just a kid as well it's
yeah
it's um now are people are people in
Scotland talking about this case at all
um not from
um what I've seen nothing on the news
about it really okay
um and nobody that I talk to really has
mentioned that either so I don't think
it's that
like a thing to be honest but I follow
American politics more than people that
I know so and like American Crime and
stuff so
um
uh yeah most people aren't really that's
not uh interested in it to be honest but
got it got it got it hey quick question
um are you familiar with a
um with uh now I don't even remember
what they're called what do you guys
call sodas you call them Fizzies fizzy
something
um I would say fuzzy juice fizzy are you
saying fizzy or fuzzy
got it okay and so is Sprite a fizzy
juice what is it it's a type of fizzy
juice
like
we also use just like names like I would
just say oh I want like Diet Coke or
whatever so we're just using it but
fuzzy dress is like a an umbrella term
it's your category it's a category like
some people would say this is soda this
is Pop this is a fizzy juice yeah got it
yeah fuzzy juice
yeah okay well you really said it all I
can't I can't think of anything else to
mention at this point
and thank you for making my call I'm
like so nervous I don't know if you can
tell you I can't tell at all you did
great
oh thank you yeah all right thank you so
much for the call
no worries all right there we go Steph
from Glasgow uh very very powerful
testimony let's go next to Isaiah from
Arkadelphia Isaiah you're on the air
Isaiah from Arkadelphia you're on the
air
you're completely uh digitally modulated
I couldn't understand a word of that
oh
um oh boy
are you a robot or is that just a voice
distortion
no I'm not wasting away you're not a
robot
oh boy oh dear God all right I'm
unfortunately I am gonna have to let you
go
um just nobody can hear what's going on
there it was uh interesting but nobody
could hear it let's try Amir from
Washington DC Amir it is your turn
my God that is just uh now I'm wondering
if it's potentially on my end let's try
Bryce from Denver Bryce please rescue us
wow how could that possibly be on my end
I don't even know what that how what
that could be
and people in the chat say that he's
clear so it's clearly on my end wow all
right well listen it's on my end but I
still can't understand a word anybody's
saying let me very quickly try to
disconnect and then reconnect let's just
let's just try again I'm going to go
back to Amir from DC let's see if that
fixed it
foreign
right yeah no it's uh if people could
hear what I'm hearing well listen I
think we're just gonna have to let me
try one more just to see it maybe on my
maybe it is on my end let's try Drew
from Fort Lauderdale Drew you're on
there
David sir oh you're perfectly clear
yes can you hear me yeah I can nice I
can hear you fine okay great
what's going on if Rittenhouse is found
not guilty on all murder charges yes
what do you think the potential uh
backlash or reaction to the public will
be
um I want to be really careful because I
don't want to encourage any violence but
I think there is a possibility of
violence after the verdict no matter
what the verdict is
yes I mean I think regardless of what
happens uh it will only further divide
and agitate us as a country I mean
I um I I worry that that's the case I
worry that that's the case and I hope
that that doesn't happen the other thing
I worry about is I believe written house
is uh going to be the next Mega Senator
right yeah no no I think he lives up in
this guy is going to be lionized and
made a hero if he's found guilty he will
be made a martyr the right is just
foaming for a sort of a zimmerman-like
character and I think to be perfectly
Frank I think Rittenhouse is more
sympathetic than Zimmerman was
absolutely yeah absolutely and uh also
is the judge's last name Schroeder yes
is that any relation to Ricky Schroeder
I have no idea who that is
Ricky Schroeder is uh the Silver Spoons
kid uh the actor who who is helping
Rittenhouse uh immediately after this
this all happened oh I wasn't paying
much attention at that time that's
interesting I I can't imagine there's a
relation
thought that was strange it but yes I
don't know anything about it
thank you for uh the time sir pleasure
appreciate the call very very much uh
let's see if we can continue it I I
guess the the audio issue really didn't
seem to be on my end
which is good news generally speaking
but
sometimes it still upsets people let's
go to Sabrina Sabrina you're on the air
so David
yes I can
all right I don't really have a question
I was just reflecting on this whole
ritten house trial and yeah I feel where
you're coming from I feel like he's a
huge victim of the whole gun culture
wrong parenting and God knows what else
I just really feel for him because he is
still a minor
um well he isn't anymore but he was at
the time of the incident
yeah but I I just wish we were doing
more as a country to sort of address
is sort of psychological impact this has
on our children you know Kyle was only
17 at the time and I know what happened
was tragic
um but it's really just heartbreaking to
see to see him waste his life and to see
the aftermath of this trial or whatever
whatever the verdict is well you know
his life may not be wasted I mean he may
be found not guilty and then gets
speaking gigs and becomes sort of like a
hero of some kind I I I actually it
remains to be seen what the trajectory
is he'll have killed people he can't
undo that
um but you know I I let's wait is it
raining where you are
no it's not I have background fan noise
so it's probably that oh I see okay all
right very good Sabrina thank you I
appreciate the call we're gonna watch
the verdict very closely
all right there's Sabrina I appreciate
everybody who called in that's gonna do
it for calls today but I do hope to take
calls again sooner than you might
imagine
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
everybody let's get into the Friday
mailbag you can email info
davidpackman.com the emails will be
reviewed they will be screened they will
be we're going to do a lot we'll check
them for bamboo fibers the way that it
was done in Arizona everything will be
done you it's crazy what we do to these
emails and then I will read a few to you
and respond we have wacky ones we have
productive ones we have substantive we
have people who were just angry with me
we have all of it all right so let's
just jump right into it first one comes
today for from Rick who says about the
Trump conviction
Rick says hi David I'm wondering why
lots of people are demanding a trump
criminal conviction nobody talking about
something that seems obvious to me any
jury is statistically bound to have at
least one Trump supporter in it if not
more one is all you need for a hung jury
so it's all for nothing he would never
be convicted of anything in a jury trial
what is your take Richard in California
yes I have said before not only is there
uh a political question here not only is
there a question of there's so many
different issues with the idea of a
trump trial a trump criminal trial
but how do you even get a fair jury and
we've been talking about last week this
week in the context of the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial and I told my story
from my jury duty experience on
something very minor compared to this
um about how hard it is to get competent
juries even for minor things I don't
know how you get a real
a jury to truly do what they are
supposed to do when it comes to a
criminal trial with someone like Donald
Trump but I think it's a merely academic
question as I've said before I just
don't think it's going to happen and I
know people get mad and say David you're
making it less likely that there will be
a conviction when you say that no I
don't think that that's the case at all
uh or that they're less likely there
will even be charges I just don't think
it's going to happen all right next one
is from Ren Ren says I have jumped ship
Pacman's MSM mean I guess they mean
Pac-Man's mainstream media narrative
stance on BS vaccines has put me totally
off well to you I say good sir
bye-bye if you don't want to watch this
show or listen to this show because of
my view on vaccination we probably
weren't meant for each other this was
probably a relationship
that you know let's go with it's not you
it's me it's not let's let's go with
that
um also another love letter this one's
more more uh Insidious this one's from
Alex Alex says why won't you address
Jewish Supremacy I saw the title I said
uh oh
uh Alex writes this is really ugly stuff
by the way you may want to get the kids
out of the room Alex writes you want to
call out white supremacy fine do it but
what about Jewish Supremacy is it
because you were Jewish and to support
I am not anti-Semitic at all but if you
seriously think we're not on to what's
really going on here
and who's really in charge of this
globalist plot
then you're wildly mistaken at least
Trump tried to fight these globalist
internationalists I should actually be
using the Alex Jones globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike Obama Trudeau macron and the rest
of these Zio beasts
um this is anti-Semitic this is
anti-Semitic and as I've told you before
I mean listen at this point we I've
explained this six ways from Sunday
folks
um coveted conspiracies are drenched in
anti-Semitism the whole concept of um
one world or Shadow government that
there's a real government it's drenched
in anti-Semitism it's just slathered
it's bathed it's sous vide in
anti-Semitism
um this is a perfect example and I don't
know if saying I'm not anti-semitic but
is even part of part of the insanity
here but that's a very very sick person
but sadly
many people hear that and they go that
person's not sick that's their politics
and I agree with them and that's
it's a very very scary thing Paul wrote
in Paul says David is there anything
stopping President Biden from using an
executive order to eliminate the
Electoral College it hasn't been needed
since the invention of the telegraph
back in 1861 why do we still use it
allow our president to be elected by
popular vote by the people period stop
wasting taxpayers money on
gerrymandering I'm looking forward to
your response Paul well so remember
gerrymandering is congressional
districts within States usually when we
talk about the effect of the Electoral
College on presidential we don't use the
term gerrymandering but I agree with the
sentiment completely the electoral
college should go I've explained why
Time After Time After Time however there
is something stopping Joe Biden from
eliminating it by executive order which
is that you need I'm going I'm going by
memory here
to get rid of the Electoral College you
need I believe it is
three quarters of the states to do a
constitutional convention
now is it and or or
two-thirds of the House and Senate
listen Biden can't do it by himself is
the point that being said the most
direct path to eliminating the popular
vote is something called the
npvic the national popular vote
Interstate Compact and this doesn't
require anything done federally it only
requires states to pledge instead of
giving our electoral votes to whoever
wins our state we will give our
electoral votes to whoever wins the
national popular vote so so for example
Oklahoma could say
no matter how Oklahoma voters vote if
the Democratic candidate wins the
popular vote we give our votes to that
candidate if the Republican candidate
wins the national popular vote we will
give our votes that to that candidate
every state has the right to decide how
they will give uh how they will
apportion electoral votes and once you
get enough States in total
whose electoral votes combine to be at
least 270 you have effectively
eliminated the Electoral College okay
um
I don't know that that's gonna happen
all right here's one I have to admit
this is one of the strangest emails I've
ever gotten this is someone who is
furious
that I mentioned that we post content to
Instagram Jeff wrote to me too much
David
too much David dear David you're my
favorite political show on YouTube but
if you think I'm going to spend my time
going from YouTube to Instagram to tick
tock or whatever other social media
you're seriously mistaken young man okay
you didn't use young man but it felt
appropriate you're a political
commentator not my life it's like you
got stock in Instagram you want to drag
people to it for the hell of it and I
would bet that a lot of your viewers
feel the same way I do
I'll see what you post to YouTube but as
for the rest I'm fine with missing it
Jeff I love it I love it and no no one
has ever it's just I sometimes
offhandedly say hey we're also posting
stuff to Instagram check it out if you
want if you don't by no means Jeff I
love that you I'm turning this around to
make it a positive thing
you are putting a limit
on how much time you're going to spend
consuming stuff on social media I think
it's fantastic these platforms are uh
habit forming these platforms can suck
you in
I I love what you're doing Jeff you know
what you tell me where your line is my
friend and it sounds like for you it's
YouTube I Love It all full power to you
Lawrence wrote to me and Lauren said
obviously the election in Virginia was
rigged and um this was we I know who
Lawrence is and this is satire and
Lauren is Lawrence is astutely pointing
out
um Republicans the new thing is if you
lose you say it was rigged they said uh
many of them even before the Virginia
election Democrats are already trying to
rig it there was some state senator we
looked at the clip last week we looked
at it again on Monday state senator who
said
um uh they're already ringing eight
here's how they're doing it Glenn
youngin won last Tuesday they never
mentioned anything about fraud or any
rigging ever again and why is that
because it's not really about rigging
it's about if we win it's not rigged and
if we lose it is rigged that's
fundamentally the only thing that it's
about and Lawrence is 110 correct let's
go to our next voicemail it's from
Barbara
Barbara responded to the not good
results in New Jersey and Virginia and
in general last Tuesday for Democrats by
saying David if Democrats don't wake up
about wokeness we will continue to lose
more please read woke racism by John
mcquarter McAuliffe was a disaster when
he did not support parents the school
anger will only grow if Democrats don't
wake up about messaging you know what's
funny about this is McAuliffe really
wasn't a wokster candidate
um and unfortunately Barb one I hope I
can call you Barb one of the
um saddest parts of this election is
yankin won
with lies about critical race Theory
critical race theory is a framework
typically taught or utilized in college
in law school
Etc
um it's not taught now the Counterpoint
that people are now coming up with is
well listen it doesn't matter if you
teach critical race theory if teachers
are uh if it's the world view of a
teacher even if they're just teaching
geography it's still going to destroy
our kids different argument and you got
to prove that you got to prove that
because critical race theory is just not
being taught to kids in Virginia and so
unfortunately I am not a wokester myself
and I've been critical of uh
elements of the left
um but uh this is this I I think this is
a little off here Barbara unfortunately
Drew wrote in with a comment on last
week's show
and said David you mentioned New Jersey
being a bad sign because of the Gap what
I meant by that was the last New Jersey
gubernatorial was like a massive win for
the Democrat and this was like barely a
win for the Democrat
um Drew says it's not necessarily a bad
sign because New Jersey voter
participation is very low in these
elections and the Democrats have not
held the gubernatorial seat in two
elections since 1976. so in my book this
is actually a win for Democrats because
we broke a multi-decade trend yes as I
mentioned you can always find
some way to characterize a situation
where it's less bad I think this is the
best the most optimistic interpretation
which is typically after Democrats win
they then lose they just they straight
up lose so rather than seeing it as oh
man Democrats won by a lot and now they
barely won
we should see it as Democrats won
normally they would lose if you go back
to 1976 and Democrats won again
so that is valid that is valid and at a
certain point it sort of starts to get
into the the level of you guys have seen
these if any of you watch sports you
know that technology and and statistics
uh and machine learning and all these
different things have made it so that in
almost any situation you can create a
statistic that seems meaningful in
sports like for example uh you know
um for games played by Leo Messi in the
southern hemisphere between December and
March when his team is leading going
into the second half he scores a goal
fifty percent of the time and then we
would be our heads are spinning and
we're saying but that why that's really
interesting but is that is that at all
relevant well I'm not even really sure
and then you can come up with that
sounds pretty good he's probably going
to score a goal you can say you know for
night games played in Latin America
uh he very rarely scores goals in the
second half when his team is when his
team is winning
you see the point we can interpret these
things and we have to find meaning in
the statistics we have to find meaning
in the statistics and ultimately the
results in 2022 are going to tell us
exactly how disastrous or not last
week's elections were for Democrats
across the country I hope that you will
get instant access to today's bonus show
by signing up on my website you can go
to joinpakman.com we really do depend on
your support
um we have a staff here we have
um you know all these different expenses
we do health care we do retirement we do
all these different things and uh I am
able to be a better employer in great
part thanks to people who value and
support the work that we do so grab a
subscription at joinpakman.com and we
will see you in mere moments on today's
bonus show
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com davidpackman